and we'd be playing video games
high-fiving each other and she would
wish that we were actually actually
getting some work done Cody Brown gets
real about the concept of brother
husbands on Sister Wives this is an
experience for me that is my life and
I'm kind of bearing my guts and I know I
feel like my job is to be truthful and
as kind as I can be while being truthful
the Brown family patriarch's wives Robin
and Mary meet up to discuss pristine's
departure from their plural marriage I
feel like I'm just starting to get to
know me I really like me during their
chat Robin reveals she's talked to Cody
about picturing himself in their shoes
I'm always trying to give him the other
perspective it's like if someone else
was in my life that you were having to
share me with you would be like in that
case yeah yeah he doesn't like that I've
had this conversation with Cody a lot of
times how would you feel if the tables
were turned he's like I don't I'm like
I'm sorry but you need to think about
this we're trying to be honest about how
we feel and so it's kind of a he said
she said the episode then flashes back
to a moment from 2009 where Mary brought
up the exact same topic and Cody's
response is kind of the same if I were
to
be giving attention to another guy
how would it make you feel
the vulgarity
of the idea of you with two husbands or
another lover
sickens me but it seems now Cody has a
different take on it I think that yes if
I didn't manage it right I could be a
nutcase if the roles were reversed in
plural marriage and I had a brother
husband
but I think she's missing something the
way guys Bond we'd be playing video
games high-fiving each other and she
would wish that we were actually
actually getting some work done yeah
Robin's not buying that oh yeah it was a
bunch of brother husbands we'd be
sitting around on the couch playing
video game I don't believe him because
whenever it comes to like guys in his
wives lives uh like my ex he gets funny
there's so many people out there that
are getting like a different view of
what a plural family is because if
because of our show so it's a big deal
to me okay so maybe no brother husbands
for the Browns and Cody's also made it
clear in the past he's not open to
adding another wife there will never be
a fifth wife and plus the TLC star's
thoughts on marriage are kind of skewed
since his split from Christine I mean
I'm still in this pretty bad place about
it my thoughts so far about marriage
ironically have been mixed but when it
comes to more kids Robin told ET last
year that isn't completely out of the
question we've made sort of promises to
you know children kind of thing so we're
always checking that and making sure
that our family is complete and that is
actually
um always a question and I'm not gonna
really talk about more than that other
than just that is always like something
that we consider and wonder about and
make sure and pray about and make sure
that we our whole family is here with us
[Music]